vous mettez un peu de muscade dans votre
deux films par an pourquoi non parce que
ça sonnait muscade
f ça va j'étais graphiste moi je
travaille dans une boîte de com en fait
c'est ben qu'est graphiste une citation
alors ça c'est passé commun pour ton
tranchait maternité bof toute façon dans
les prochains jours ma propre boîte
ça c'est super ça super peut-être un peu
tard maintenant qu'elle attend un enfant
assez dommage ma chérie s'arrêter bien
qu'ils pensaient enfin j'ai pas ya plein
de femmes qu'il le faut je vois pas
pourquoi je pourrais pas le faire
tu sais moi aussi je pensais je suis
bien et ma thèse que je fais le tour du
monde et puis on a eu toi toi est ton
frère vous l'annonçait à vue aurait été
tellement merveilleux si tu ne savais
pas bah oui je serai prix nobel de philo
la presse que ce machin mais déjà créé
nabel philo ça n'existe pas et puis
surtout ça n'est pas du tout ce que je
pense ben encore atteint c'est
exactement ce que tu penses maman tu
nous as créé on a détruite ça y est
c'est reparti et coup tellement va pas
revenir là dessus un gîte cette fois bon
ouais bah j'ai peut-être un peu bu je me
suis excusé
puisque vous me demandez ville et je
jure comme un petit rap de gratteur star
vraiment serait jamais une mère comme
toi écoutez mathieu voici tu viens ici
pour dire des sorts apparaissent à la
peine dans le gras à la maison avec vous
ça tombe très bien parce que c'est la
dernière fois qu'on vient ici tu vas
t'en fous tu verras jamais voilà tu es
contente
c'est incroyable tu étais un peu dur non
de le [ __ ] ta mère tu le connais
demande et perd 7 heures pour encore m
11 15 bonne nuit
[Musique]
mais réveille-toi peine aller vers une
élection fait la bernique n'a pas balayé
toi
[ __ ] [ __ ]
et ma maman c'est toi qu'est-ce que
c'est ce bordel j'ai déjà eu deux
enfants je veux pas taper un troisième
accouchement
1 comment sortir de son corps la méthode
de voyage astral tu vas où
je ne sais pas encore j'y vais mais
c'est ta faute aussi là bas s'il est à
dire que tu feras jamais être comme moi
que je verrai jamais mon petit fils
un pari suka je vais pas ressortir de
bain mais arrête toutes façons tout et
tout le temps ma faute c'est ça je suis
la source de tous tes problèmes et emma
comment tu peux le dire ça moi je me
suis sacrifié pour vous mais maman mais
on n'a jamais demandé autant à appâter
marrant toi qui se serait occupé de vous
si je mettais pas sacrifier un et qui va
s'occuper lui là pendant tu vas monter
ta start up belle peut-être mais oui oui
madame
[Musique]
pardon maman
j'aimerais que tu étais pas aidé avec
lui en a je regrette pas complètement ce
qui est chouette quand vous étiez petit
[Musique]
aimes tu as raison je prends que j'y
suis allé un peu fort avec ma mère ya à
java - de l'amour
[Musique]
et